[Música]
bienvenidos a el debate de france 24 soy
marina colorado el 18 de octubre los
bolivianos volvieron a las urnas y una
vez más tal y como los resultados
preliminares mostraban en 2019 la
mayoría del pueblo de bolivia eligió al
movimiento al socialismo el más luis
arce heredero de evo morales ha
conseguido en palabras de su opositor el
candidato del partido comunidad
ciudadana carlos meza una contundente
victoria que no necesitó de una segunda
vuelta las elecciones anuladas en 2019
desencadenaron en violentas protestas en
las que hubo decenas de muertos y
cientos de heridos los comicios también
resultaron en la salida de evo morales-
del país y su exilio en argentina y de
la asunción de jeanine áñez como
presidenta interina de la nación
cuál es el mensaje de bolivia con esta
nueva victoria del socialismo cuáles
serán los retos del gobierno de luis
arce qué papel tendrá evo morales en
todo esto y que podrá hacer la oposición
para analizar todo esto nos acompañan
desde la paz nuestra corresponsal
mery vaca y nuestros invitados erika
brockman analista política y ex
parlamentaria y jorge ritter ramírez
politólogo y catedrático de marketing
político y gubernamental en la
universidad católica boliviana
muchísimas gracias a todos por estar con
nosotros hoy en el debate de france 24
antes de comenzar el análisis me
gustaría recordarles que desde sus casas
pueden enviarnos comentarios o preguntas
a través de nuestras redes sociales con
la etiqueta numeral el debate efe 24 y
no se encuentran como arroba france24
comenzamos ahora con en nuestra
corresponsal el meriva acá y quería
preguntarle cómo avanza el recuento de
los votos en la paz
o la marina qué tal amigos de france24
comentarles que el conteo de votos ya
está en la recta final se podría decir
que ya se ha marcado la tendencia final
que va a tener este resultado y que se
ha consolidado la victoria de luis arce
del movimiento al socialismo en primera
vuelta y por mayoría absoluta de hecho
él está con un porcentaje superior al 50
por ciento y tiene una diferencia mayor
a 20 puntos con el segundo que es carlos
meza que se ha declarado como el líder
de la oposición por otro lado también
debo comentarles que el más va a tener
mayoría en el senado pero todavía no se
sabe si va a llegar a los dos tercios
las proyecciones indican que no y que
probablemente tendría que concertar en
esa cámara para aprobar temas claves de
la agenda nacional
estas cifras muestran claramente un
retorno del más a bolivia y eso a eso le
vamos a dedicar la primera parte del
programa que dice esta amplia victoria
de lo que pasó en 2019 con las
elecciones que fueron tildadas de fraude
por la organización estados americanos
por ejemplo vamos primero con erika
brockman para su análisis
muy buenas noches un gusto y agradecida
por este encuentro por este diálogo para
poder dar cuenta de lo que ha sucedido
en bolivia un saludo para américa jorge
y por supuesto para marín ha coronado el
que les puedo decir al respecto creo que
desde el punto de vista político
bolivia a través de su voto ha
demostrado que el movimiento al
socialismo no había sido un partido que
sólo dependía del más que el movimiento
al socialismo es un bloque político
representa un bloque muy importante la
sociedad boliviana que
es mucho más que evo morales o sea no
había sido un partido caudillista sino
representa un gran entramado de
organizaciones sociales que hacen aparte
de la cultura política y de el entramado
más arraigado que existe en el país
atrás de sectores populares no solo
indígenas sino fundamentalmente de
organizaciones campesinas sindicales y
esa es su base constitutiva y de origen
por lo tanto tiene una presencia
nacional después de 14 años en tiempos
de bonanza verdaderamente ha consolidado
su presencia como partido predominante
eso es lo que primero puedo decir ha
probado su consistencia como
organización política y probablemente
hoy día se inaugura una nueva fase de su
existencia con las oportunidades que le
presentan ser uno de los pocos partidos
organizaciones políticas que está
demostrando que puede superar a su
propio liderazgo después me voy a
expresar respecto cómo
esta elección respecto a la coyuntura de
la anterior elección que definitivamente
desde mi punto de vista fue una elección
en la que los bolivianos tuvimos que
perder el tiempo por el empecinamiento
de evo morales- de reelegirse
probablemente el año pasado
arce catacora era el candidato y no era
evo morales probablemente ese 20% que
decidió no votar por él en esa
oportunidad hubiese decidido por otra
opción hubiese hubiese ganado pero si no
era el perdón
y hubiese ganado definitivamente la
elección también el más pero creo que la
gente no quería la perpetuación de un
solo líder creo que esa es una madurez
política una señal muy importante que el
de la que tenemos que aprender les dice
entonces les dicen los resultados de
estas elecciones del 18 de octubre la
anulación por parte de los estados de la
organización de estados américanos jorge
de richter que cuál es su opinión al
respecto
marina buenas noches un gusto compartir
también el panel con erika y con comer y
bueno uno de los primeros elementos que
el pueblo boliviano requiere cerrar es
esta infausta narrativa que ha
significado y que ha conducido a bolivia
a una ruptura institucional y a un
paréntesis de una plena y absoluta
democracia en ese sentido hay que poder
contrastar ya de manera inequívoca dos
hechos dos elementos fundamentales los
resultados del 18 de octubre pasado de
este domingo con los resultados del 20
de octubre del año 2019 los resultados
ahora son superiores en al menos 8
puntos en favor del movimiento al
socialismo entonces esto significa de
manera clara de manera contundente y es
evidente también que lo que aconteció el
pasado año no fue un fraude electoral lo
que ha sucedido es que no se con no se
ha comprendido desde los sectores del
centro hacia la derecha cuál es la
composición política y social primero de
un partido político como el movimiento
al socialismo
cuál es su relación con la enorme
corporativa de organizaciones sociales
populares del país muy diversas todas
ellas pero que conforman la manera la
forma de organización en el sustrato más
esencial de nuestra sociedad y esta
diversidad de organizaciones sociales se
articula de forma homogénea y en tiempos
electorales y el ejercicio del poder
político se hace se vinculan en un
estado en una alianza con el movimiento
al socialismo son dos entidades que
actúan aliadas en momentos electorales y
en momentos de administración política
esto el pasado año también ejerció esa
acción político electoral y en este
sentido hoy en día ha quedado
completamente desvirtuado lo que ha
significado un informe de la
organización de estados américanos que
sin lugar a dudas a guardar atrás de
atrás de sigo en el contenido de su
cerca de 90 páginas algo más allá
de una simple denuncia de irregularidad
de su intención de manipulación del voto
hubo una intención de ruptura
institucional de forzar la ruptura
institucional de un país que otra
explicación se puede encontrar en ese
sentido marín a que un pueblo pueda
votar masivamente masivamente superando
los niveles de participación 3
tradicionales con cerca del 87 por
ciento de participación y hacerlo en
función de aquel que podría haber
cometido fraude este sin lugar a dudas
va a terminar tiene que terminar siendo
un evento esclarecido en el país porque
a la institucionalidad democrática de un
país al paréntesis democrático a la no
vigencia plena y absoluta de la
constitución política de un estado ya la
interrupción de un mandato
constitucional no es algo menor que
pueda quedar como un evento anecdótico
esto hay que mirarlo y ya no existen más
pruebas
de estudios de reflexiones econométricas
estadísticas etcétera respecto a lo que
sucedió el año pasado se ha manifestado
la población en una línea política y en
función de ello está claro que no hubo
un fraude como bien dice usted jorge
ritter más de casi el 87 por ciento de
la población votó hay que decir que el
voto en bolivia es obligatorio para los
que residen en el país y es voluntario
para los que residen en el extranjero
mery vaca que se dice en las calles de
la paz cuál es la sensación que existe
ahora mismo en el país donde usted está
que es en la paz por ejemplo
mira yo creo que hay dos miradas
respecto a los resultados marina una
mirada de tranquilidad porque finalmente
hay un resultado contundente claro y la
gente lo ha entendido de esa manera
incluso los oponentes almas han aceptado
su derrota y han aceptado que el
presidente electo del país se llama luis
arce sin embargo también debo comentarte
que en santa cruz se está gestando un
movimiento en contra de los resultados
electorales ha habido algunas
movilizaciones en las últimas horas de
las denominadas plataformas que
básicamente son grupos ciudadanos que
apoyan al candidato de creemos luís
fernando camacho no quieren aceptar
estos resultados y de hecho se están
pronunciando en contra de los mismos en
todo caso yo diría que es una
movilización que no tiene mucho futuro
porque la mayoría del país en este
momento está tranquila existe calma y ha
aceptado los resultados porque se trata
de eso de una institucionalidad
que los bolivianos están acostumbrados y
bueno han ido a las urnas y las urnas
han hablado
el protagonista de la crisis del año
pasado fue el ex presidente evo morales
quien como dijimos exilio en argentina
la gran pregunta que ahora se plantea es
si el mandatario va a volver a su país
al respecto escuchemos las palabras del
virtual presidente de bolivia luis arce
no lo que yo dije es que él puede venir
al país el rato que quiera porque es
boliviano y no solamente todos los
bolivianos
todos en ningún boliviano se puede
restringir que entre al país pero en el
gobierno yo tengo que decir tiene tics y
no está en el gobierno
todavía es una incógnita evo morales ha
hecho expresado su intención de volver a
su país pero recordemos además que
morales tiene más de 30 procesos penales
abiertos en su contra voy de nuevo con
nuestra corresponsal mary vaca que se
sabe sobre estos casos abiertos en
contra del expresidente boliviano
buena marina el expresidente ha señalado
que son 30 esos procesos sin embargo es
probable que muchos de ellos simplemente
sean anuncios de procesos los que sí se
han instaurado son alrededor de unos 8
hay unas 8 demandas en contra del ex
presidente tal vez la más seria es una
demanda por supuesto terrorismo debido a
que existe un audio en el que se escucha
una voz que sería la del ex presidente
evo morales en la que instruye bloquear
las ciudades del país esto ha ocurrido
el año pasado después de su abrupta
salida del poder
eso es digamos uno de los casos que ha
avanzado más porque existe una orden de
captura en contra del ex presidente y es
por eso que él no puede volver al país
al menos no por ahora no existen otros
procesos también marina te quiero
comentar por ejemplo uno por fraude
electoral que le ha instaurado el ex
presidente carlos mesa que es el
perdedor de las elecciones él ha
instaurado este proceso en contra de los
supuestos responsables políticos de este
fraude porque existe otro
en contra de los responsables técnicos
de este caso también existe otra demanda
planteada por el gobierno
particularmente por el ministro de
gobierno arturo murillo por supuesto
estupro y trata y tráfico de personas
debido a una supuesta relación que evo
morales habría mantenido con una menor
de edad y también hay un caso por el
bloqueo de caminos de agosto de este año
cuando los sectores afines al movimiento
al socialismo han impedido a través de
sus bloqueos que pasen insumos médicos
oxígeno hacia los hospitales y también
se ha planteado una demanda en contra de
evo morales por el supuesto apoyo que él
ha dado a través de su cuenta de twitter
a estos movimientos como verás son una
serie de demandas penales que existen en
contra del ex presidente pero también te
tengo que comentar que en bolivia la
justicia danza al ritmo del gobernante
entonces es probable como el mismo evo
morales ha dicho que estos ojos se vayan
a caer ahora que el más está nuevamente
o va a volver nuevamente
precisamente sobre lo que menciona ahora
mismo mery vaca nuestra corresponsal
quería preguntar un poco si quedaría en
entredicho el papel de la justicia
boliviana si el ex presidente morales
vuelve a bolivia y no se llevan a cabo
procesos en su contra vamos primero con
erika brockman
bueno hay que señalar que
definitivamente la justicia hace
muchísimo tiempo está en entredicho no
estamos hablando solamente durante este
último período sino también durante el
periodo de evo morales de pronto muchos
el vídeo proceso se derrumbó
prácticamente se lo archivó y se hizo
una costumbre y algo ordinario las
detenciones preventivas que duraban años
la justicia está en una crisis que
también tenía
ciertos rasgos de poca credibilidad
inclusive antes de evo morales es un
problema estructural que estamos
enfrentando pero evidentemente el abuso
de poder 14 años la concentración de
poder el ínter presidencialismo
contribuyó muchísimo a que se invada
absolutamente
la independencia de los otros poderes yo
creo que es importante y una señal del
cambio de ciclo
en el actual en el cual va a ser el más
también protagonista este cambio de
ciclo
obliga a enfrentar el tema de la
justicia debemos señalar otra cosa
s muchas de los de las causales y las
imputaciones y los delitos a los cuales
está haciendo referencia el caso del
terrorismo concretamente paradójicamente
evo morales está siendo víctima de la
definición que él hizo de terrorismo él
introdujo una ley una un concepto
absolutamente draconiano y poco
concordante con los derechos humanos a
nivel internacional tanto así que ha
sido observada esta ley está imputación
ya porque él la hizo para otros pero
nunca pensó que iba a ser aplicada para
sí mismo entonces yo creo que estas
cosas tienen que interesarse hay una
porción de la población que no está
dispuesta a que esto pase como si no
hubiese habido impunidad hay que
recordar que el tema del fraude lo la
primera imputación de fraude y la
detención de los vocales electorales el
año pasado fue instruida por el propio
evo morales el tema del fraude si bien
es una narrativa creo que
como dice muchos autores las narrativas
políticas pueden encubrir verdades y
mentiras pero sí pero la justicia
independiente es precisamente la que
tiene que esclarecer la verdad de los
hechos y desde mi punto de vista esa
narrativa debe ser superada con la de
por los hechos y no necesariamente el
hecho de que hoy día hoy día haya ganado
el más y tengas el respaldo abrumador
abrumador de la gente que significa de
que no esté pendiente este tema
simplemente por el hecho de la victoria
creo que amerita una autocrítica de
parte de uno de los partidos más
importantes y que está marcando historia
en el país una autocrítica respecto a lo
que sucedió y a ese intento ese intento
pero persistente por apostar por una
postulación inconstitucional por cuarta
vez que lesionó y lastimó muchísimo la
propia constitución y los principios
constitucionales que tiene la
constitución que se aprobó por evo
morales o se hace
estimula la democracia representativa se
lastimó un instituto de la democracia
participativa y directa y esos elementos
son elementos que verdaderamente han
dejado huella y han marcado un
sentimiento ciudadano por el que eso
asignatura pendiente del más y de todo
el sistema político comenzará a respetar
mínimamente la institucionalidad y ese
modelo democrático instaurada
precisamente por el mismo
ya no escuchábamos hace unos minutos el
virtual presidente de bolivia luis arce
dijo que morales puede volver al país
puesto que él es boliviano no hay ningún
problema pero que su papel en el
gobierno no va a estar asegurado jorge
ritter cree usted que es así a pesar de
que morales sigue siendo el presidente
del partido movimiento al socialismo
y marina hay que tener siempre en cuenta
cuáles son los perfiles psicológicos y
las características de la personalidad
que tienen los diferentes actores
políticos el señor arce sin lugar a
dudas para llegar a la presidencia del
estado para lograr la votación que ha
conseguido también aunque ésta pueda
depender de muchos factores pero es él
quien ha liderado ese ese proceso quiere
esto quiere decir y expresar que tiene
una personalidad definida y clara en los
puntos que son absolutamente centrales
hace muchos años atrás se estableció un
mito de que en realidad no gobernaba el
señor morales sino el vicepresidente
álvaro garcía linera y ahora se está
intentando nuevamente apelar a
argumentos inconsistentes por supuesto
de que estaría una figura detrás de el
gobierno del señor arce y esto no suele
suceder durante los años anteriores
gobernaba evo morales y tenía
absolutamente claro claro lo que
significaba el control del poder y sus
relaciones con el vicepresidente y otras
autor
pero en bolivia tenemos siempre una
rapidez para apelar a esta fantasiosa
argumentación de que hay alguien más
detrás del poder esto es sin lugar a
dudas esto va a significar en el tiempo
que viene la presencia y va a llevar a
la presencia del señor evo morales en el
país por supuesto que sí y también que
se establezcan algunas puntas de poder
tres 3b vértices de poder muy claros en
la recomposición de lo que es el
movimiento al socialismo y lo que
significa también su poder esas puntas
son el señor arce el señor evo morales-
del señor
choquehuanca esto va a ocurrir es un
partido vinculado como le he señalado a
los movimientos sociales muy muy grande
y por ello dentro a su interior
coexisten y conviven diferentes
facciones buscando siempre espacios de
poder como en cualquier estructura
política muy grande y esto no va a ser
la excepción lo vamos a poder observar
habrán seguramente crisis habrán
contradicciones y tendrán que construir
día lógicamente
a partir de mucho de mucho esfuerzo
posiciones homogéneas para tener una
visión de conjunto y quiero también
señalarle algo rápidamente el respeto de
la institucionalidad y el tema de la
narrativa del fraude marina también
tiene que pasar no solamente por una
evaluación de lo que han sido los 14
años de la gestión del señor evo morales
no existe un momento mayor que un
proceso electoral donde se pone en
consideración todas y cada una de las
fuerzas políticas que sea la población
quienes los evalúan pero también hay que
señalar de manera clara que los respetos
institucionales pasan por no generar
rupturas institucionales como la que
ocurrió en noviembre del año pasado en
eso hay que ser absolutamente categórico
hoy en día se están buscando por
supuesto y esto va a ocurrir seguramente
con mayor intensidad en los próximos
días distintos argumentos para tratar de
diluir o de
aminorar el impacto de lo que fue
aquello de denuncia monumental de fraude
electoral de robo de la elección y de la
institucionalidad y en esa perspectiva
hay que ver que el primer respeto a la
institucionalidad es no generar una
ruptura en la institucional gracias a
una ruptura de redondela interrumpa
precisamente quería hablar un poco de
esa ruptura porque morales sabemos
claramente es una figura polémica y que
divide al país en cierto modo a pesar
del enorme apoyo que ha tenido el
partido más en estas elecciones debe
entonces morales aceptar un papel más
alejado de la política para que el país
se pueda recuperar y pueda sanar un poco
y haya más unión vamos con erika
brockman
bueno yo creo que es una pregunta
pertinente creo que al interior del más
que su partido tan fuerte va a haber un
debate muy intenso a fin de definir cuál
va a ser su práctica política y su
comprensión y el sentido de la
democracia en términos de cohesión
coexistir con el otro por el adversario
creo que evo morales y un núcleo
importante que tuvo el poder el núcleo
del poder del año pasado
durante los 14 años tenía una lógica de
la democracia muy particular entendía la
política como un campo de lucha un campo
de lucha donde el adversario era un
enemigo a eliminar
siguiendo toda esa lógica de los
autoritarismos que tenían una visión de
una democracia con un solo partido ese
era el ideal de alguna manera que estaba
en el espíritu jacobino de alguno de sus
actores josh y ese es la conflictividad
esa es la visión ese es un tema
tremendamente tóxico para la democracia
por eso es que me parece muy importante
el leeds que han puesto ahí el
encabezado diciendo de que este nuevo
gobierno está dispuesto a generar nuevos
nuevos puentes nuevos puentes y nuevos
lazos sin reencuentro entre los
bolivianos y creo que esa tónica la va a
introducir de una manera muy especial
particularmente choquehuanca
choquehuanca que inicialmente era el
candidato digamos preferido por parte de
los movimientos sociales de base
campesina sin embargo hay que reconocer
que el perfil particular de él de arce
catacora es una es un perfil muy
importante él ha ganado porque
él es el depositario emblemático de lo
que ha significado la política económica
de los 14 años de bonanza por mérito
propio y por que mantuvo un sistema y lo
ha reconocido muy prudente en términos
macroeconómicos ahora le tocará lidiar
en época de vacas flacas el otro
elemento que quería decir que rupturas
institucionales traumáticas en los 38
años de democracia hemos tenido en tres
oportunidades la primera oportunidad
cuando se vio por los movimientos
sociales insurreccionales y movimiento
popular acortar el mandato de el
resident del primer presidente del ciclo
democrático de la era democrática empezó
el ciclo de la democracia apartada en el
que asocian al neoliberalismo ya y esta
a ese sistema político como otra ruptura
institucional que tiene que ir a una
transición institucional también
compleja es el caso del 2003 donde esta
ley se derrumba el mundo neoliberal y
hoy día
se tiene una lamentablemente una tercera
ruptura de la continuidad de un gobierno
constitucional y donde está precedida
por 21 días que hay que reconocer la
cantidad de actores que estuvieron en
esa revuelta ciudadana que derivó en la
solicitud hasta de los propios aliados
de evo morales de que era conveniente de
que se retire del gobierno estamos
hablando de la central obrera que era
había mucha violencia violencia de los
extremos que estaban implicados en los
factores políticos de extrema derecha y
también dentro del propio más de los los
focos más radicales entonces de fuego
enfrentamiento casi de sociedad a
sociedad donde al final de cuentas y ahí
podemos hablar sobre el rol de las
fuerzas armadas desde hace muchísimo
tiempo que desde hace tiempo que piden
que el ejecutivo asuma una
responsabilidad política sobre los
hechos de intervención de la policía y
el ejército y bueno eso ha generado que
definitivamente
el rol de las fuerzas armadas hoy día
sean muy debatida inclusive en este
gobierno que ha militarizado y ha dado
una señal de militarización muy
importante creo que parte de la el
triunfo de luís arce catacora en esta
circunstancia por muchos más puntos de
los que tuvo evo morales
casi a punto de ir a una segunda vuelta
frustrada del año pasado
el punto favorable ha sido precisamente
en la mala gestión el abuso de poder la
mala comprensión de lo que significaba
un gobierno de sucesión de sucesión
constitucional frente a una crisis tan
importante que habíamos vivido en una
bolivia polarizada nos quedan pocos
minutos de programa quería pasar ahora
un poco a hablar en muy ver brevemente
desafortunadamente porque nos queda poco
tiempo como dije de cuál es el papel de
la oposición y cómo tiene que afrontar
los próximos cinco años por ejemplo el
partido de carlos mesa jorge cuál es su
opinión al respecto de cómo debería
afrontar la oposición estos nuevos cinco
años
son dos modelos de gobernabilidad entre
los que ha elegido la población y eso es
una gobernabilidad unipolar la que se va
a acomodar ahora con el movimiento al
socialismo y el y la otra opción era una
gobernabilidad multipolar en función de
una necesaria alianza de partidos
políticos de acá en más
hay que señalar de manera importante que
el señor carlos meza por lo que él ha
sido su votación en estos momentos está
alrededor del 29 por ciento esa votación
le confiere si una una segunda una
segunda fuerza pero hay que señalar
también que comunidad ciudadana no
presenta los rasgos característicos de
lo que significa
y un proyecto político con perspectivas
futuras
esto ha sido básicamente la presencia de
una agrupación ciudadana para un evento
electoral específico como es el de este
año y su participación en el 2019 en ese
sentido habrá que observar primero si el
señor carlos meza tendrá una vigencia
política en los años que siguen no para
una nueva candidatura dentro de cinco
años sino básicamente para poder
cohesionar a su bancada parlamentaria si
eso como primer elemento el segundo es
que hay que observar si está si la
búsqueda de algunos liderazgos que
puedan tener tendencias descollantes no
vaya a fraccionar lo que significa
comunidad ciudadana pero en definitiva
su presencia tendrá que reducirse al
papel de fiscalización que no es un dato
menor y seguramente coadyuvar en algunos
acuerdos específicos cuando se requieran
los dos los dos tercios
y rápidamente porque cada vez nos queda
menos tiempo quería hacer una pregunta
acerca de los mayores retos que creen
ustedes que van a tener que lidiar el
gobierno de luis arce vamos primero con
mery vaca 30 segunditos por favor mary
yo creo que son dos marina uno de ellos
superar la crisis económica en la que
está el país en este momento el pib ha
caído en 11% prácticamente la economía
nacional está en un descalabro y yo creo
que ese es el principal reto que debe
enfrentar el nuevo presidente y el
segundo marina me parece que tiene que
ver con la concertación nacional con la
reconciliación con el encuentro entre
los ciudadanos ha habido mucha
confrontación los últimos años sobre
todo desde el 2016 cuando evo morales
desconoció cortados de un referéndum y
es hora de que los bolivianos se
encuentren se reconcilien y que se pueda
salir adelante como país vamos ahora con
erika brockman también 30 segundos y me
disculpo de antemano por la brevedad
no evidentemente la economía parece
hacerlo todo y es la base estructural
para poder después dar respuestas y
satisfacer las demandas de los
ciudadanos y bolivia hoy día tienen que
preguntarse de qué vamos a vivir tomando
en cuenta que tenemos una crisis muy
profunda una crisis que no es solamente
de que es producto de la pandemia y la
mala gestión de este gobierno sino
también que se viene acumulando con
déficits fiscales y reducción
significativa de las reservas
internacionales y una baja impresionante
y sima de las capacidades productivas de
nuestras materias primas eso va a
significar un gran reto y creo que de
ahí
el tema de la institucionalidad y la
construcción de la institucionalidad
instituciones claves va a ser parte
también de un gran pacto de concertación
para enfrentar los retos y colaterales a
la economía y finalizamos con el
análisis de jorge ritter sobre los retos
del gobierno
fundamentalmente si usted marina quiere
atender la crisis económica necesita
tener un país pacificado lo que se ha
conseguido ahora es un momento de
tranquilidad en función de los
resultados electorales esto no significa
porque hay otras fuerzas también
importantes que el país ya tenga un
rumbo definido de pacificación absoluta
eso es algo que se tiene que trabajar y
se si se establece solo en la
construcción de diálogos y que
incorporen la complementariedad social
el otro factor es que las regiones
tienen que dialogar porque son son
poderes contrapuestos sin necesariamente
tienen que dialogar para poder también
incorporarse en la línea de la
pacificación resuelto esto usted tendrá
un escenario apto para poder
enfocarse en lo que significa la crisis
económica que es fundamental muchísimas
gracias a nuestros dos invitados de
nuestra corresponsalía ustedes
muchísimas gracias
hay más en france24 punto com
[Música]